This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross. We're continuing our series of some of our favorite
interviews of the year with Jeffrey Tambor He stars in the Amazon
series transparent as a transgender woman making her transition from male to
female late in life.
Tim Gore won an Emmy and a Golden Globe for his performance timbre also costarred
on the T.V. series Arrested Development and The Larry Sanders
Show transparent was created by Jill Salo way and was inspired by
watching one of her own parents come out at the age of seventy five as a transgender
woman in season one of transparent timbres character Mort
started transitioning to Maura revealed her female identity to her three adult
children and
ex-wife and started appearing in public in women's clothes our interview was first
broadcast December tenth just before season two one up on Amazon.
We started with this clip from season one's first episode. Maura is at
her transgender support group and is describing how she just started testing out
appearing in public wearing women's clothes.
When I went to Target and I just I took
her you know I mean and I got into you know the checkout
line and the girl at the cat's Register
said I need to see some ID with that credit card of
yours and you know that's fine. Right.
And I just knew I said this is going to not be good. This is going to get
ugly hands. So she just kept looking at me.
And then she said
Oh I thought that you know.
And she rung up
the batteries
and I was of. Oh that was a big victory.
And I didn't I was trying to not cry in front of this woman you know.
Thank you for Sarah Maura thanks for being vulnerable about one more thing.
I made a commitment here last week that I was going to come out to my kids and I didn't do it.
Because it just wasn't time you
know but I will and it will be soon.
I promise you I promise.
I'm going
to
maybe are so selfish.
I don't know how it is I raise three people who cannot see beyond themselves.
Jeffrey Tambor welcome to FRESH AIR. How did you find the part within
yourself that could identify as a woman because you need to identify
as a woman to play this part.
Well one of the things that I I am amazed at is I thought that.
The
hardest part would be the external would be the oh the nails and the hair
and makeup and the dress and heels and the blah blah blah blah blah and
actually that wasn't the hardest what that was very very very easy for me and I liked
it I mean who doesn't like a good many pedi and
so that came all very very easy.
What's interesting about playing more is that I get to use more
of Jeffrey than I've ever used in any role and
I think that's a remarkable part about it and truly the most
surprising part about doing this role.
Can you give me an example of something you have to play as Maura that you never had a
chance to do before or that you learn to get yourself. Well I do know I do
notice that. I'm playing more I am I much more and I want to be I'm sort
of careful of the words because they're so stereotypical but I do I do find myself
much more sensitive and I find myself much more vulnerable less less
protective and less protection or less armor.
That's a real that's a real surprise to
me now your character isn't glamorous and fashionable in the way that for instance.
Laverne Cox just one of the stars of Orange Is The New Black
is when your character more addresses in more formal
attire like a long purple dress with like sequin a spangly things all
over it I am reminded of what my parents' generation the women of
my parents' generation used to wear to like weddings and bar mitzvahs.
I'm wondering when you dress in that women's formal attire. Who do you see when you look in
the mirror do you see people that you know relatives that you know
friends. No I don't I actually see as I said I do see more
I remember when. When we were just
preparing and we sort of did our first sort of
field trip and we were going to take more out for for the first
time and I was going to meet more of for the first time and so we went into
the bathroom after a long long talk and I
was scared
stiff and we began the makeup and I did the hair
and or they did the
hair and I remember more just you know just appearing on my
face and that's exactly how she looks and we dressed her up. And we went
to we went out dancing at a place called the ox
wood and I remember walking through the lobby of that
hotel my legs were just shaking and I I said to myself never
never never never forget this moment because this is exactly how it
is to live
as more. And the odd thing is no one was looking at
me so what was it like for you to feel like you passed will
know if I passed.
I think I got through the night. There's people staring at
you not of the ox what and not at the hotel that was what was very odd.
I did
go on another field trip where I did have that where I went to
a grocery store and I was in the middle of the aisle.
Just like doing what if Mora went shopping and. I wanted to find out what morrow
would wear.
And what she would buy and things like that you know just not to sound too actory but that's how you research and
that's how you find and one person did. Stare at me in
the aisle and had a somewhat of a sneer on their face and I also
said Do not forget this. This is what it looks like to get
clocked I don't know if they were looking at me using Well that's Jeffrey Tambor
or that a trans
woman I have no idea but I
do remember I remember the sneer on the face and it wasn't pretty.
Whereas in the position of having recently started appearing in public as a
woman in women's clothes as a woman. And
sometimes she kind of passes you know a notice and just blends in
another times
people stare at her with kind of you know confusion or
anger
hostility and I'm wondering like in your own life as you as
Jeffrey Campbell or if you were ever in a similar position where people live
just based on how you looked that you got you know hostile or mocking
looks from
people I have two things I can point
to but what's dangerous about me pointing them out is that I could
never say that either one of them even equals what it is to be a.
Or of course no woman or man so whether I do know what it is to be other
ised in the
community. When I was a young boy in San Francisco. I remember
being sent home playing with a friend and.
I remember the mother saying tell Jeffrey to go home. And I
said to the girl why she
goes my mother says that you're the people who killed Christ and
I got home and what was the worst part of that is when I
took getting is I'm
saying I remember when I told that dinner to my parents and I
remember them looking up into each other's eyes and I will never forget that.
Because it was it wasn't even fear it was like
there it is. So I kind of know what that
was and also I remember. I grew up and I
don't think I've ever talked about this I grew up with a list. I talk like this.
Because I had braces. And so my name is Jeff. So
everyone in my school called me Cliff. Unfortunately. And I say no
calf calf and so they called me Cliff Cliff people would make fun of me because I had this. Lisp.
How did you lose the list was taking off the braces
sufficient no. I went to I went to so
many people and at San Francisco State College I still had
it and there was a man named Dr Joe MIT
sack who one day said Have you ever heard your lisp and I said no.
So he recorded it and he said that's you're saying.
S.. He said this is how you say S
S And I went oh yes that's
correct and that's what it took wowed to hear. I had to hear it.
That's a smart. Isn't that amazing yes.
So after somebody accused you of
killing Christ because you're Jewish and you told your parents did
that lead to things that they had never told you before about anti-Semitism.
Either they or
your grand no experience no because we were in their generation
that where we were they were they were second generation and that was the
thing where everyone was trying so hard to
blend and so hard to fit in so nobody you know they never talked about
it absolutely never never talked about it you know I was bar mitzvah the
gunpoint by the
way. OK so this walks us right to a clip. I want to
play from the first season. So there's there's a flashback in the first
season where we see that.
As you're starting to figure out that you know you really want to dress as a woman and that there are
other men who are that way too you find out that there's
this like weekend getaway this kind of camp for men who dressed as women and
you very much want to go problem is it coincides with the butt
mitzvah of your daughter.
And so. One weekend she comes to you and says this is all
in flashback she comes to you and says I don't want to do my butt mitzvah. I don't believe
in God what's the point of this. I don't want to do it and you kind of say
OK
fine and then you use that as an opportunity to counsel about mitzvah.
And then kind of sneak off to this camp where you can dress as a woman with other
men can Camille Yeah yeah so flashing forward to the
present in the final episode of the first season. Your daughter has
just found out the facts why you agreed to counsel her but mitzvah and on that day
she's left totally alone.
You're at this. Trans at this camp. So she finds out that you really went to this camp
and now she's going to confront you about that here goes.
So Ron tells me that you CAN SOMEONE BUT let's both say to go to dress up camp in the
woods that you're now. Not at all.
Oh I'm going to leave.
I'll let you cancel it.
I was
thirteen and the you cancelled you but there are ten year olds don't get to cancel
but with honey. Yeah and so if you bought me it's you know you made an agreement. I respected
your mind. I can't get you to do your house or what do you want me to point a gun at your head
so don't be so self-centered that there's another world out there. It's not involved
on me all right.
Allie all my
feeling in this room I'm not I'm the one with the phone or the I believe. Oh that's good
that's rich because I don't need she really isn't who wants to do it you know who need guidance
in life and what
on earth was I doing with God you know if you keep your voice to Henry and I've moved out. We
haven't because that's our family religion right.
You believe Chris a little bit too much. I mean even for you there's no money to go to college but don't
tell anybody you don't touch their god only you know why are you always pushing money on
you
because Vyvyan of all girl.
You cannot do everything.
You know you have so much more to say now than when I was writing your
tracks giving you loans which by the way are actually loans because you
don't pay
back. The understand how one
cent. I'm paying for your
life.
I don't need or want or give us about your money
you
can scream at me any more that I'm an adult. OK So
there we go it settled
done of question. Now that you're on the payroll
anymore. You like me.
If I think you. Any
money. But you haven't
talked.
A great scene from transparent from the first season with my guest. Jeffrey Tambor
as
Maura and Gaby Hofmann as his daughter.
Allie So he says to her in that
scene about the bottom it's the when she says What did you want me
to do point a gun at your head and you said that you were bar
mitzvah at gunpoint by gunpoint and he was being euphemistic
So what happened to your bum it's funny. I was bar mitzvah to Beth
Shalom. And I had
I had I had trouble. I didn't quite get it all part of part of
it was had a teacher a wonderful teacher but he could be
very strict and I
remember I asked him he said I said Can I ask
any question and he said yes and he said Take your time questions take
a long time. What is it. And I said how do we know there's a God and he said get
out to me out of Sunday
school. And that's an answer and I
had had a
little problem with it and also I just wasn't into
it anyhow I had a bar mitzvah. I learned it from Cantor Bornstein.
Actually I think I was a little dazed during it. Do you remember there used to
be a drug called Milltown
do you know but yeah it was like one of the early anti-anxiety
pills Yeah yeah. And so my mother. We got all the car
my mother
said my mother was really interesting and she said You notice I said yes
I'm really nervous she
goes here and she gave me a mill town. You were drug
basically basically a drug drug that my bar mitzvah. But I gave a
great speech. What did you say great. I just kind of went off script and just
started thanking anybody. That was in the. You were feeling
good I was feeling good in the moment.
You've said in other interviews that your
father gave you the advice don't celebrate they'll take it away from you
and this is this is a kind of advice from you know like long periods of.
Of suffering and persecution that the Jewish people you know face
through through the centuries but were there times in your family where it was an
official celebration it was your duty to celebrate like you're not supposed to be to happy but in these days
it's your job to be happy.
Well my dad's thing was I mean we practically had don't celebrate printed on the napkins.
But his big thing is I would say Dad dad dad. I mean I'm on Broadway with George C. Scott and
he would say Don't don't say anything. Don't tell anybody Dad Dad
I'm getting married. Don't sit nothing nothing. Don't do anything
so he honestly because he was taught don't celebrate. He'll take it away from you and
his parents thought that and his parents and parents but because
if you did celebrate and you were visible. It could be very
very dangerous part of it is just trauma but part of this fact.
You were up in San Francisco your father was a flooring contractor but I think you'd been a
boxer before that is that right.
Yeah he was a. Light Heavyweight. Legend
has it legend that he sparred with Joe
Lewis and again. Let me let me really reiterate
legend and his
mom made him give it up because she was so worried worried about it but I do remember once
when he was selling tile out in the front of the store. He was
a very big man he was about six foot
one and he was stooped over in this position. It was very odd it was a very
submissive position he was talking to this guy's short guy and I later found out that was his
boxing trainer. And he was assuming the position that if you do in the corner listening
listening to his trainer it was a very memorable thing. I also remember once
when I was. After he passed away and I really really loved my
dad I was very close to my
dad you know he was very very nervous about my being an
actor and I went to clean out his office.
I never knew that he just never really he just worried worried worried about me being an actor he
didn't say much you know in other words and I went to get his trophies and the stuff out of his office and
I open his office door and there there wasn't a single piece of wall space that did
not have my
picture or reviews on it it was on the leave a pole.
He had saved you. But he never said anything.
So that's great he was kind of proud and kind of bragging to himself in the space that no one would
see exactly which is exactly right and then exactly that way right.
And they're exactly what that generation did he did he did see me on Broadway.
I was with Robert Preston in sly
fox. And then he saw me just before he passed away in my
first film role with Al Pacino in and justice for all. So that's what was
good I later found out somebody came up to me.
And said you know your dad super death the Met and I said
what they said yeah your dad held a spear at the Met on
Saturday supernumerary Another was an extra in the Metropolitan Opera.
Yeah yeah. And so I wrote this so maybe there. I think there was a grudging sort of.
There was a lot more to be said about Barty tambour than he was letting on to.
So one of the great roles that you played was on the Larry Sanders Show and Larry
Sanders was played by Garry Shandling and Larry was this late
night Tonight Show style
host and you play. The
sidekick Hank and your catchphrase was want to do it
for us. Hey now you know. And so I want to play a
scene from The Larry Sanders Show in which Larry Sanders tells you
that maybe it's time to drop your catchphrase Hey now.
So here's my guest.
Jeffrey Tambor with Garry Shandling on the Larry Sanders
Show you know Hank this isn't easy for me but.
Would you mind not doing it on the show anymore
because. Frankly I don't know you really are you telling me
that when you you know your.
You do
this that you know I'm to the same ethnic station that isn't the same as my you
know their you just said it again and you know I asked you not to say it.
Because they all states he doesn't even exist you say now in a sense I think.
HE No that was real funny you know what
Hank. It's not even in the dictionary Hey OK this is this is no use
we know in the second circuit you say. And of course my sidekick
a and of course my psych you can't know. And that's a sentence.
There's a scene in The Larry Sanders Show with Garry Shandling and my guest Jeffrey Tambor or.
Everything when I watched Garry Shandling I said whatever he's doing is what I believe
in that's what I believe comedy
is it's not Pat It's not automatic It's not
super performed. It's sort of messy and very very
funny and he goes past the laugh to get something else.
So this final question. This might
be heading into territory I kind of want to. I want to kind of want to talk to you for the rest of my
life so sweet I would enjoy it if you so you
know you've been sober for I don't know more than a decade. I don't know how. The
years exactly fifteen one of it's liberating to
be sober in the sense that you know an actor has to be kind of naked in a lot of ways like you're
inhabiting somebody else but you have to feel free to go to
uncomfortable places and everything and to not be to be open to feeling
things and if you have a secret like if you've been secretly drinking or something that
that has to kind of close you off in some way.
So I would assume so I'm wondering if it's easier
to be open in a way that you must as
an actor when you're sober. Well even though people think
it's all or freeing to you know to
be. Actually I can only speak for me in my life
I find that in sobriety. I feel much more.
And I have much more depth. I also feel not to segue. But as being a parent.
Of five kids. I can bring much more to my acting
and so I'm all about anything they give you more feeling and more depth.
You also feel more and in feeling
more there are there there. The waters can get rough but
so what let the waters be rough. I don't think if I had
if I hadn't been so bright don't think I would have even been around for
transparent All right thank you for that yeah I
think your resources are feeling your
resources are Depp's your resources are
learning your resources are touching and feeling and
to me sobriety helps and AIDS all
of Jeffrey Tambor I enjoyed our talk immensely. Thank you me
too much for doing
this me to you. OK So we do we talk
every ten years is that correct.
We can speed it up a little bit. I think we're going to have enough.
Jeffrey Tambor stars in the Amazon series
transparent Our interview was originally broadcast December
tenth just before all of season two one up. Tomorrow we
continue our series featuring some of our favorite interviews of the year we'll hear from Mark Ronson
whose record uptown funk featuring Bruno Mars was one of this year's biggest
hits Ronson also produced Amy Winehouse his hit
Rehab and we'll hear from Aziz Ansari and Alan Yang co-creators of the
Netflix comedy series master of none. They previously worked together on Parks and
Recreation hope you'll join
us
with FRESH AIR's executive producer is Danny Miller our technical
director and engineers already Bentham Dorothy Ferebee is our administrative assistant
Our associate producer for online media is Molly C.V.S. Roberta Shorrock
directs the show. I'm Terry
Gross.